the Samsung Galaxy Bots 2 Pro and the
pixel buds Pro are the two new flagship
earbuds on the market with nothing
coming in with your own ear one buds
Sony we at with the wfx m5s there are a
lot of options for tws and C earbuds so
let's hash it out to see who wins the
battle of the buds also I need to know a
couple things the air ones have been
with me the longer since like last year
the pixel buds around a month or two
back and we just received the Galaxy
buds 2 Pro the other thing is though the
er1s are nothing's flexible earbuds
because they're the only earbuds nothing
has they're here on the basis of what's
new and how it stands out against Google
and Samsung's latest Flagship buds first
off the Samsung Galaxy plus 2 Pro out of
the box these are the most comfortable
earbuds I've ever used in a long time
I'm not just talking about how soft the
ear tips are but the material used for
these buds are soft to the touch as well
and with the ergonomic design which is
Samsung's enhanced wind flow technology
reduces ear canal pressure and I have to
say they are comfortable to listen to as
well and I think they don't the Saturn
is used for the case as well as the
earbuds so everything is just nice and
soft and C wise it does well I can't
think of noises from the low to mid
ranges though you can still hear stuff
on the higher side next up are the
Google pixel Bots Pro they are best
described as a no-nonsense pair of buds
that sound and feel great we got the
ones in charcoal and they look stealthy
and are low profile ANC is great on
these things not because it's a depth of
volume but adaptive PMC so it still
works at the lower volumes pretty well
lastly we have nothing's ear one and day
two were a surprise nothing I started
off strong with these earbuds when it
comes to their signature clear
Aesthetics of course this cannot compare
with the bigger boys like Samsung and
Google's earbuds but they definitely
have their own domain within its price
range NC wise you honestly get the
performance that you pay for with a lot
of the higher end mid ranges still being
quite audible I've been using them for a
couple months now and I tried to drown
out the Noise by playing Heavy Music at
the highest volume like I do from bands
like chamber of matters and loaf but I
think I damaged the right side of the
buds so noise hits like myself would
definitely need something that can last
but they are perfect if you're looking
for something that's cheaper and if you
don't listen to the kind of music I
listen to for long periods at a time so
now down to the comparisons the cases
between the three are all nice and
compact with the nothing being the
largest of the three the nothings will
slip out of your hands because they made
a plastic and will get scratched up
pretty easily so you may want to put
them in a pouch which I kind of wish
nothing gave in their box but it is what
it is the little depression in the
middle is a nice little grip to open up
the case and pop the buds out but
because the area is so wide it might get
a little finicky placing the buds back
in and taking them out because they will
sort of Glide around the surface I'm
just hoping the second iteration or the
ear twos would have deeper charging
Chambers for the buds all in all they
are real pretty to look at and are
definitely a conversation piece so the
ear ones give you four hours of play
time with 24 hours in total with the
case the pixelbots Pro case which is
basically an ear has a sort of matte
finish and feels comfortable to grip but
because it's white deadly other stuff
gets caught on it pretty quickly other
than that it's super easy to remove and
put back the buds in because they slide
right in so they're up to 10 hours of
listening time with 20 hours with case
in total with ENC on these Samsung
batsuit Pros on the other hand has the
smallest one factor and has the most
comfortable material of the three I'd
say it's like taking the two best things
from the nothings and pixel buds cases
it's small it's comfortable the bar
bubble looks great the presentation of
the buds are what I wanted to see and
they're secure and easy to pull out like
the pixel buds Pros it's a solid case
with five hours of listening time and
with 18 hours in the case so the pixel
Bots beat the other two out in battery
life but the Samsungs are great in terms
of the case again the nothings are not
in the same weight category as the other
two and it's literally their first
offering so I'm a bit more forgiving the
Samsung buds 2 Pro Sound is managed by
EKG and it's a bouncy base especially
when listening to tracks like underwater
by Taiwanese math or outfit elephant gym
and the highs and mids are clear when it
comes to instrumentation and vocals even
without the EQ options it seems like
they added a little extra bass in the
base EQ but that's a class for me and
I'm guessing a lot of other people out
there who like base your tracks however
I will say that there are only mine
adjustments made to the parts to approve
from its predecessor the first gen
Galaxy bus Pro so if you have those
you're not going to notice much of a
difference in terms of performance
unless your ears are tuned like an audio
file but they're a strong introduction
to what Samsung has to offer if you're
looking to hop on their training for
audio products and if you're already
using an Android phone or preferably a
Samsung the pixel bots on the other hand
listen to songs like toes goodbye Charli
xcx's hot bodies and heavier tracks like
Heavens Broken Heart by boundaries the
pixelbots pro does relatively well on
goodbye the drivers in the pixel but
handle the acoustic guitar pretty well
however there is a little at a base and
travel to its EQ so when instrumentation
gets a little more complex it makes it
hard to appreciate those parts but
honestly if you're just an average show
these work fine and you won't really
notice it the extra base helps with the
thumping of Charlie's tracks and with
how abrasive boundaries tone sounds the
louder bass and treble give us what US
noise hit one loud volumes with some
segments of clarity the nothing here
ones are EQ for the low emit ranges
compared to other earbuds in their price
range which are usually base heavy to
the point it's literally just base but
that doesn't mean they've neglected the
bass tones they're just more accurate
low and mid-range frequency responses
listening to coverage of Boya the kick
of the drum plays out noticeably with
the bass hitting nicely as Yvette hits
early guitar notes loud and clear
there's more clarity in the base EQ but
there's also an option for changing the
EQ to boost the bass for a little more
kick in the lower frequencies and one
for clarity that focuses on the mids and
pulls the notch down on the highs and
lows which leads me into this all three
have preset EQ options in their apps but
it wouldn't hurt to let us customize
only cues especially at the price we're
paying for the Samsung and pixel gun
pros I get the ease of access for others
but I think having some room for
experimentation will be great also I
won't really say much about the
microphones on these butts but I'll let
you hear how they sound like so leave a
comment below and tell me which one's
your favorite
this is how the Samsung Galaxy Bots 2
Pros sound like in a busy office
yes one two three one two three these on
these Samsung Galaxy Box 2 Pros
these are how deep pixel Bots Pros sound
like an ABC office
microphone sounds like in a busy office
one two three these are the Google pixel
guns
this is how the nothing gear one sound
like in a busy office
very busy office
very busy office one two three one two
three This Is How They sound like
like on a busy street there's a lot of
events going on and
sounds like as we're walking through
this busy Street
cool thing about this episode guys about
to prove is that you can turn on ambient
mode while you guys want to call so you
can hear surroundings so much better
compared to the other two and yeah he's
already
sent them together about two Pros
this is how these Google pixel Bots grow
sound like on a busy stream we're
outside right now there's no
construction going on people are walking
around cars are passing by so yeah this
is how they sound like this is the
adapting ear once this is called the
sound like on a Disney Street we are
walking and crossing the road right now
so This Is How They sound like in a very
busy environment on the street level so
yeah nothing here once also just for you
Riders and gym Reds out there the pixel
buds pros and nothing EO ones have an
ipx4 rating while the Samsung Galaxy
buds 2 Pro have an ipx7 or anything so
you don't have to worry about them
getting wet and not working lastly their
companion apps the Samsung Master Pro
and Google pixel buds Pro have a range
of similar features while the nothing
app is super minimal they work
relatively well with locating your bud
services and whatnot but I have to say
the fit testing feature of the Samsung
Google Apps remains to be seen if they
help or not if anything it feels like a
sort of pseudo test to reassure that the
fit is great but other than that is
quite all in all I would pick the
Samsung's purely for how comfortable
they are its presentation and the way it
sounds but if I had to recommend
something it would be the Google pixel
but because you save a couple bucks
without compromising on sound and
features and also its battery lasts a
lot longer than the other two the
nothing here ones are definitely up
there for me for buds in this price
range but of course there are other
earbuds out there that offer the same
quality with more customizability so
nothing has a lot more to learn but they
have started off remarkably well for
their first offering and if you like
these kinds of comparison videos follow
us on all of our socials here leave a
like and comment and subscribe to us we
have a ton of content coming your way
foreign
[Music]